>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Stephen Winick: Hello.
My name is Stephen Winick, and I'm
here at the Library of Congress
with the band BeauSoleil,
or the BeauSoleil Quartet,
as they're called today.
And I'm interviewing them for
the American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
So, I'm going to sort of
address some general questions
to all of you.
In particular, a question about
what the Cajun music scene was
like when you were growing up.
So to sort of set the scene
for how Cajun music has changed
over the last 30 years or 40 years.
>> Michael Doucet: Keep going.
>> Stephen Winick: Fifty years.
>> Michael Doucet: Well, I
don't think it was ever a scene.
You know, the music was created for
the community, just for the people
in Southwest Louisiana, as a way
of communicating news, and I mean,
it's very, Louisiana,
it's a beautiful state,
but it's very hard,
and you work hard.
But you play hard too.
So the music was very
much a part of that.
My father had five sisters, and
you know, two of them sang ballads.
And then we would have
these parties, you know,
family get togethers where
there was a meal or whatever
where everybody would show up and
everybody would play something.
It didn't matter what,
whether it was a violin
or a trumpet or piano, whatever.
And I think everybody
just really liked the fact
that it was still sung in French.
The old people liked it because
it was called old people's music.
We never called this
Cajun music growing up.
And, it was French music, or la
musique Francaise [phonetic].
And it was just something,
you know, me personally,
just kind of took for granted.
It was like, you know, somebody said
when did you learn
your first Cajun song?
I said, when did you learn your
first Christmas song, you know.
It was kind of the same thing.
But everybody did it, and I'm
talking about the 50s now, 1950s.
And there was 22 civil
parishes in Southwest Louisiana,
it's like a triangle,
that speak French.
And all those different
parishes had different songs
and different people.
A lot had been forgotten because
the original recordings, you know,
with the RCA victor coming in,
they wanted to sell Victrolas,
so they were recorded
for commercial use.
That was from like '28 to '36.
And then World War II happened.
A lot of people, you know, realized
what they had when they went away.
Because we were so, it was
different, like no other place,
obviously, speaking French.
And so I think there was a
resurgence, always a resurgence
that happened then
in the 50s, the 60s,
and then of course,
it was television.
And when we had our first
local station in Lafayette.
It was KLFY TV.
And every Sunday morning they
had [inaudible], which was a show
that Aldus Roger played on.
It was like this big band.
I mean we used to hear
like an accordion
and fiddle player or somebody.
There was like twin fiddlers, steel
guitar, electric guitar, drums,
you know, bass and the whole bit.
So that was like another
resurgence I think.
But I think music has
always been in our culture.
So that wasn't, you know, that
was something that was just there.
What happened sort of in the
30s, people were punished
for speaking French
on the school grounds.
So either they left school.
You know that joke, right.
You know, when they went to
math class they said say one.
One. They say, say
two, they said bye.
So, but it like happened,
it's not really a joke.
It happened.
But a lot of people preserved it.
And in Southwest Louisiana
growing up,
a lot of people didn't
speak English in the pier
because they didn't have to.
And so that was that.
Now, what happened to us, for me,
is that when someone died that was,
you know, a proponent of this music,
you know, not only did you grieve
for the death, physically death,
but whatever history they had
because our history was basic oral.
With the music too, but our
history of our culture too.
So for us, I mean, it's like
we didn't want to see that.
So we decided, well we have
to do something about it.
How do you do something about it?
You learn the music.
And just like that.
I mean it's not for no
reward or no end result,
the thing was just
it needed to be done.
>> Stephen Winick:
So you got a sense
that the older generation
was passing away
and you decided it was
time to [inaudible] yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: Because nobody
was looking at it as it should be,
as we thought it should be, because
it's not just two-step and waltzes.
I mean there's a lot of
information in there.
There's a lot of cultural
information.
And we thought we were isolated.
We though nobody in the
world knew about this stuff.
And that started to change
a lot in the 60s too,
when some groups went
to Newport, etcetera.
It happened to us when we
were invited to go to France.
But anyway, I don't want to
be long-winded about this.
But it was something that I
just want to say that the people
who held the music did
it because they had to.
I mean, it was just a passion.
It was a remarkable passion,
not because of any kind
of reward except the fact
that they knew these songs.
And people, like fiddle
players, like [inaudible].
I mean he would sing song
about kings and queens,
and we knew he never
knew any kings or queens
or even knew what that was.
But the fact the music keeps
on going, regenerating.
>> Stephen Winick: So you mention
that early period when, you know,
in the 20s and 30s when there
were commercial music made
of Cajun music.
Were those still influential on
people when you were growing up?
I mean, were they still
listening to those records, or?
>> Michael Doucet: Well, you
don't have those machines, 78s.
What happened, a lot
of, this is one example.
This is like, I mentioned
Amede Ardoin,
who was the first creole really
accordion player and real prolific.
And we play about 80% of his songs.
I mean Cajun repertoire,
well creole repertoire now.
There was a blind, almost
blind Cajun guy, white guy,
who learned all his songs.
And most people thought, this
guy has really earned his name,
came up with all these songs.
And nobody could reference
back to the 78s.
The first time I really listened
to a 78 was on a 33 1/3 LP
from Chris Strachwitz,
Arhoolie Records.
We did this, a five series
that we just went crazy.
Because we thought, oh
this is a long time ago.
It's ancient history.
And then when I first met Dennis,
the first time I met Dennis,
I said I thought you were dead.
He said not yet.
So that's a big jump too.
>> Stephen Winick: And I mean, you
also mentioned that sort of moment
in the 60s when groups started
going to places like Newport.
>> Michael Doucet:
But they were not,
I mean at home they
didn't believe it.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Michael Doucet: You know,
it wasn't like they were going
to make a living about
this, you know.
It was just, it was regular people.
You know, people, nobody
really made a living at this.
I mean you played Saturday
nights or whatever.
I mean we had a lot of people
came from there like Vin Bruce
and Jimmy C. Newman
who went to Nashville.
Doug and Rusty Kershaw, etcetera.
But you had to get out.
>> Stephen Winick: Right, right.
>> Michael Doucet: Of Louisiana.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Well tell me about some of the guys
that you sought out and worked with.
You know, start with Dennis
since you already mentioned him.
>> Michael Doucet: Well
Dennis, like I said,
I first met him I thought
the was dead.
You know, it was a joke.
And he says, no.
So I went to study with
him where I had a grant
for the National Endowment.
And with his brother-in-law
Sidney Corville [phonetic].
Because, to me, that was the
oldest form of Cajun music,
what we call French music.
And it was so, the
twin fiddles styles.
Which was not popular and
not played by anybody else.
This recorded in the
20s, or late 20s and 30s,
so this style was not there.
A lot of modern musicians
would always say,
why are you wasting your
time learning that music.
I said, are you kidding?
This is the essence.
But it wasn't the popular country
and westernized Cajun music.
It was dance hall at that time.
I was very much interested
in the blues in this music,
and there was two bluesy
creole musicians.
One was Canray Fontenot, and
the other was Bebe Carriere.
Because they had a certain
style that you didn't,
there was always blues in our music.
I was always interested,
where did this come from?
You know, in Louisiana.
Because Louisiana blues
is different.
I mean there are 12 bar, 16 bar, you
know from the Delta in Louisiana.
But these Cajun French
blues is a little different.
And I guess the, and of course, the
Balfa brothers, both Will and Dewey,
you know, they were very influent,
because that totally,
we love their music.
Because there was acoustic,
when it was away from Louisiana,
[inaudible] Louisiana
it was electric.
But nevertheless.
And another man that I found,
he name was Varise Conner.
And I said Conner, what is that?
It's Britain.
He says oh no, my grandfather
was an O'Conner.
So, O'Conner.
And he played a certain style
very lilting fiddle style
that he had never played
with an accordion.
So it was kind of, you know,
because when you play a fiddle
and accordion, people like
Hector Duhon, he was another guy.
And he played a certain sickening
style that was pretty amazing.
But he, the accordion that was the
main instrument because it was loud
and etcetera and a lot
of things like that.
So those are the people basically.
>> Stephen Winick: So Mitch,
why don't you mention Dewey,
because I know you
worked with Dewey as well.
So what was that like?
How did you meet him, and how
did you start to play with him?
>> Mitchell Reed: I used
to go to Marc Savoy's Jam
when I was learning,
when I was a kid.
And I played string bass over there,
and one time when Mac Savoy was
like, hey Mitchell, come over here.
Dewey's on the phone.
I was like what?
Dewey Balfa?
Yes. He needs a bass player.
His bass player got in a
wreck the night before.
>> That's terrible.
>> Mitchell Reed: And I had a gig
at the Liberty just all of a sudden.
And so Marc hands me
the phone, he was like,
alright, do you know Cajun music?
I said yeah.
He said you know the chords?
He said okay, don't mess up tonight.
I'm going to trust you.
So I got to the Liberty, and my
family's all from Mamou, and Dewey,
the Balfas are all from Mamou.
And so when he found
out who my family was,
then I became part of
the family, you know.
And it was awesome.
And then we came here in '98
and played for two weeks.
And it was like Jamie Berzas.
There was a guy, Dudley
Abair [phonetic] maybe,
I think, that played guitar.
But we played with
the Lawtell Playboys.
And Dewey was awesome.
I never took fiddle lessons
because my hero was Dennis McGee,
and I never could really pick up
the way Dewey wanted me to play.
He was a really strict teacher
like when he'd teach you,
you have to learn the chords first.
And it was that Balfa style.
And I was learning more
the melodies from Dennis.
So he'd get fed up and
say okay, go practice.
So I was mainly his bass player.
>> Stephen Winick: Well you
had talked about the difference
between Cajun fiddle and
other regional fiddle styles.
I mean it's quite different.
And I think people can hear it
but maybe not understand
what they're hearing.
>> Mitchell Reed: Yeah, it's a lot
of different styles, like Mike said,
creole like you have
Canray and Bois Sec.
And they played creole
and the Cartier family.
They played the same tunes that
the white players were playing,
but it just had that, it had that
kind of different groove to it.
And I always like creole.
That was kind of my thing.
And to me, Dennis McGee, although
he was a white, Irish guy,
he played more of that creole style
because he'd play with
Amede, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Well, I mean, just the purposes of
people who might be watching this,
of course, we use that word creole,
and it means so many
different things.
>> Michael Doucet: Yes.
>> Stephen Winick: So in this
context, explain what we're talking
about when we say creole.
>> Michael Doucet: Well Creole is
like rural French-speaking
people of color.
I mean that's the easiest
way to do it.
And, because there were a
lot of free people of color,
even though they were black,
in Southwest Louisiana.
And they were side-by-side
with whoever was there,
but mostly French.
Not only Cajun, but
they were French too.
But they learned, there
was American songs.
I mean, there was a lot of, you
know, in the Library of Congress
when Alan Lomax went down,
and he recorded Wayne Perry.
Anyplace like [inaudible] hen.
What other songs?
And Sittin' on Top of the World.
But it doesn't sound
like that at all.
So it's, you know, wherever it
comes from, whether it's Appalachia
or whatever, the music is a
reflection of the landscape.
And Louisiana, it's
definitely, it's muggy, it's hot,
it's muddy and the pace is slower.
So I think that adds to it.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
I think I hear more drones
in the fiddle playing than I
do in most of the other styles.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah,
and that's the early style.
They said they played in
Nova Scotia or [inaudible],
but also there was a Frenchman, I
believe his name was C. C. Robin,
you know, Robin, who came
through and mentioned
that he heard these twin
fiddles in Louisiana.
He said it sounded like
something you'd hear in France.
This is pre-accordion.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
Well the scene changed a
lot in the 70s and 80s.
I mean Cajun music went through
a sort of acts of development,
and people outside Cajun country
came to even know that there was
such a thing as Cajun music.
How did that affect people who
were playing it in Louisiana?
>> David Doucet: That's
a good question.
I don't know.
There's a lot more people
got interested in it.
See I always remember, Mike was
talking that in 1968 they started,
that's when I first
took French in school.
I was in fifth grade.
And there was an organization
called CODOFIL,
the Council for the Development
of French in Louisiana.
So they had these signs everywhere.
You know, speak French.
It's your heritage.
Everywhere.
It was all in French.
And apparently, the
culture was going,
you know, I was too young to know.
But when I was in high school and
Mike started BeauSoleil and Coteau.
I got interested.
He called me up one day and said
come, let's go record a record.
I'd never really played.
I was learning guitar, you know.
I was into folk music,
acoustic, all that.
But I know that we did that, and
people looked at us like weird.
They thought we were all Canadians.
I swear to God.
They still think we're Canadians.
>> You're young, you
play this music.
>> David Doucet: It got, you
know, in the 90s, 80s and 90s,
we played and played and played.
And I think that younger people
got interested in playing music.
They thought it was neat.
I don't know if they speak it.
We're losing the language.
>> Right.
>> But I think that was part of it.
And also, what I've discovered now
is that people that had heard us
and the older people play that
live elsewhere, outside Louisiana,
they're all retired now, and
they want to learn how to play.
So there's a lot of
interest in these camps
where you go and you learn.
And they come to Louisiana, they
retire there, and they dance.
And some of them try to tell you
what you're doing isn't right
and all that.
But that's beside the point.
They have a better way.
But that's, I think that's
the popularity of it.
The kids, at home, there's, you
know, you go to the festival
at Cayenne at Lafayette, and
there's all these people,
they play, and their good.
They don't sing very
well, I don't think.
But they play.
It used to be just accordions.
Because apparently an accordion is a
little easier to play than a violin.
Now it's all violins and
fewer accordion players.
It's really interesting
how it does that.
So, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> So I don't think, you're
not going to lose the music.
But I don't hear any
of them singing.
They all can play.
>> Stephen Winick:
That's interesting.
So is the language going as well?
I mean.
>> Michael Doucet: Well as
I say, in the 1970 census,
they said there were a
million French-speaking people
in Southwest Louisiana.
That may be an exaggeration.
In year 2000, there were less
100,000 French-speaking people.
So that says it right there.
But it goes through like
different windfalls.
I mean you got to, like I said,
on the first television
station, there was French there.
They had an announcer by the
name of Jim Olivia [phonetic],
who got up every morning
at what 5:30?
>> 5:00 in the morning.
>> Michael Doucet:
And he had groups on.
Yeah, French royalty.
He had groups on.
It was all in French.
And so it was there because
that was the main population.
And then, you know,
Louisiana, because it's been,
basically it's basically
agriculture.
And then when they found oil, then
you have the influence of a lot
of other people, which
changed the music, etcetera.
And the transition happened
in the 60s basically.
I think that the early 60s
you started seeing that.
For us, we were like, it
was the young people born
in the 50s who can remember it.
And then we kind of got
together, it was about 12 of us.
It when it was like, you know,
Barry Ancelet, because he went
on to become a professor
and a folklorist.
I mean, there were so many
people, some French people
who were there that helped us out.
The [Inaudible] used to
write in French and English.
And this was young people.
And when we were, when
we were young.
But that influenced that in a group,
like Dave mentioned, like Coteau
and BeauSoleil, we weren't
a first young people.
I can't even remember people my age.
I mean I think, oh what's his
name from Kaplan, you know,
Jessie Lashay [phonetic], he
and I are about the same age.
And that's about the
only person my age.
So it was fully, so you'd
have to go through Marc
because he was an accordion
player and maker, and Marc Savoy.
And he was, he's 11
years older than I am.
So he was really at that
point where he saw more
of the French than we did.
And Marc and I obviously
played together for,
still play together basically.
But it was people like
that who had this vision.
And so we always strived
to do it right.
I mean it was, for no
reason, we we're trying
to be popular or anything like that.
We were trying to get the song out.
It was like the first, the first
record we recorded was in France.
It was just happened.
I mean we were in [inaudible]
and this guy came up
and says, I like your music.
Do you have a record?
I said no.
Would you like to make a record?
I said yeah.
And he was like the
head of [inaudible].
So I said we don't
have too many days.
No problem.
But the really first record
in the United States we
did we did for Floyd.
I tried to do the whole gamut of it.
First of all, we had the French
and English translations.
And the second one it wasn't
just two steps and waltzes.
There were ballads.
They were tin pan alley songs.
They were creole songs.
They were reels and stuff like that.
Because that's what we were
learning after uncovering this
where they just go to a dance,
let's get drunk or try to get laid.
You know, it's like a
whole different picture.
So we played what we call, I guess,
back porch music or kitchen music.
>> Stephen Winick: So when you
said Floyd, that's Floyd Soileau?
>> David Doucet: Yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Okay.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah,
it was called The Spirit
of Cajun music, the
Cajun Spirit Music.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
So David, something that you
said, you said, you know,
you weren't really playing the
music, you were learning guitar.
And that sort of brings
up that question
of how much guitar has changed in
the way it's played in Cajun music
over the last little while and
you being a big part of that.
What, you know, what did you do
to integrate different guitar
styles and to Cajun music?
>> David Doucet: Well, I
had a couple of heroes.
The old Doc Watson's
my hero, you know.
But at home, there weren't
that many people that played.
There was three guitar
players, three or four.
One was Rod, I loved the
way Rodney Balfa played.
And then D.L. was there,
D.L. Menard.
And then Preston Manuel who's
always played with Dennis.
>> Yeah.
>> David Doucet: So he had some,
impressed, by this time, you know,
as a teenager or just, you know,
I just graduated from high school,
you go to Fred's Lounge in Mamou
and, Saturday morning, what, 8 a.m.,
something like that,
go to a radio show.
And these guys, they'd be drunk at
8:00 in the morning playing music.
But I'd watch him.
You'd see Nathan Abshire
would be there,
would be the accordion player.
So you got to see these guys.
So you see Preston interact.
And I thought the stuff
he did was good.
And the guy played the
chords, what I heard.
So for me it was like, when
you blend all that together
and the stuff I was learning,
the folk, I liked folk music.
That was my thing.
I listened to Paul Simon.
Then I said, well I discovered
Doc and a couple of blues guys.
I said this is like
really cool stuff.
And I thought, you
could put them together.
I really don't know what
people are doing now.
I don't live in Lafayette.
I don't really go see that many
bands, so I don't know what they do.
And occasionally someone
says, well I heard, you know,
they say I'm trying
to play it like you.
I learned this from Mitchell,
because Mitchell teaches.
So he tells me that people
are interested in that.
And I think it's really hard to do.
It's hard to actually be heard
and set up to play acoustic,
like what we do is very difficult.
And it takes a lot of patience.
And like we have our
own sound guy usually.
It's hard, and not
everyone can afford
to do that or want to do that.
And acoustic guitar
is just not allowed.
It's not loud as an accordion.
It's definitely not
as loud as a fiddle.
You know, to make it
fit and try to do stuff.
So, you know.
>> Michael Doucet: Fit that sound.
>> David Doucet: That's what we do.
And when I play solo I play it
all finger style in open tuning.
So that's, from a Hawaiian
influence, believe it
or not, which is really bizarre.
You know.
>> Stephen Winick:
That makes sense, yeah.
>> David Doucet: But the
whole deal was the rhythms.
I thought the rhythms were cool, you
know, getting into it, learning it.
When he called up it's
1977, in August,
we're going to make a record.
Come practice.
You know, I'd never really
thought about it before.
Never really listened to it.
You see it on TV and kind of
laugh at the old people dancing.
That's what, you know.
These people are like what
30 years older than me.
They were old, you know.
They were like 45 years old.
>> Michael Doucet: That's old.
>> David Doucet: You know, and
they were dancing, and it's like.
Folks would make fun of it because I
think they made fun of the language.
If you spoke French you were stupid.
You know, you were uneducated.
>> Michael Doucet: But
they both spoke French.
And my father always [inaudible].
>> David Doucet: But
if they didn't want us
to know what they were
talking about,
what do you think they'd speak?
French.
>> Michael Doucet: You see that'
show you learn how to speak French,
because I'd say, hmmm,
they used to play cards.
And you could only stay in the
room where they played Bourre.
And you could only stay in the room
if they tell you something to do,
and you knew what it was and
you'd answer back in French.
So I was adamant about
learning that, because I wanted
to learn all the dirty
words, you know.
And so I did.
>> David Doucet: That's the truth.
That's how it was.
It was different.
They want you to go
learn French in school
but not French, what
they spoke at home.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah,
but they kept it up.
I mean it was, Paulette
and I both spoke French.
>> David Doucet: Oh yeah.
We all understood it.
>> Michael Doucet: That's
what was, people our age were.
>> David Doucet: Well the
old people in the country,
if you see the old people,
that's all they spoke.
They just spoke French.
The gardener my grandmother had,
he didn't speak a word of English.
But you have to understand
what he was saying.
You know, stuff like the guy
that lived next door
can come wind my watch.
He'd say that in French because
he couldn't, he had arthritis.
He couldn't, Arthur-itis
[phonetic] like they called it.
It's like, you know, that is weird.
When you think of it like now, it's
like, man, what a weird time it was.
It was like in the late
60s early 70s was a mess.
>> Michael Doucet: There was no,
it was not about commercialization.
When Paul Prudum [phonetic], who
had a small restaurant in Appaloosa,
moved to New Orleans, burned the
red fish, it became a phenomenon.
And then people started
looking at it.
And then Glenn Pete did a movie.
I think movies had
a lot to do with it.
He did one called [inaudible].
And then there was another
movie called The Big Easy,
which was terrible.
But nevertheless, it took place
in New Orleans and brought out,
you know, the Louisiana music.
And that began this whole
thing of Cajun restaurants
in all parts of the country.
I mean, we got some stuff,
I don't know what it was,
but it wasn't what we were used to.
So we have it in our contract,
do not serve us Cajun food.
>> David Doucet: Under absolutely no
circumstances feed the band Cajun.
>> Michael Doucet: And so we were
in St. Louis, outside of St. Louis,
anyway, this little
town, and the guys says,
somebody's cooking for you.
I said oh no.
And we walk in there and
it's like a magna light,
and it's got about ten
pounds of crawfish.
And I said oh, this might be good.
Well, you know, ten pounds
of crawfish would feed
about 20 people if
they weren't Cajuns.
Well, we ate the whole thing.
So that kind of thing.
But then, that gradually changed.
And of course, it became commercial,
you know, blackened chicken
and stuff like that, you know.
But that all, with that,
we're excited about the music
because they would have
to have the music with it.
So that influenced a lot too.
And my wife always says, you know,
well you're the reason why it's
like this because we'd go
out and say, you know, come.
Well, they came, and
they didn't leave.
And what's odd about it is
that you can't go to the Cajun
or a zydeco dance and have just
people from Louisiana there.
That's, when we played we said
just people from Louisiana.
Check their licenses, you know.
Because I mean it's
changed that much.
It's become a thing, like David was
beginning to have his tirade about.
But it's, we caused it in a way.
And it's good because
it helped people.
But it's, I can't even tell
you how different it is now.
I mean just the fact.
I mean Marc Savoy says,
there's no more Cajun.
They're just rednecks.
You know, and so that's
a whole different story.
Let Marc answer that one.
But I mean, that's his
perspective and, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: But I
mean, that also opens up kind
of another question which is,
so you were saying, you know,
check their licenses, only
people from Louisiana.
But not everyone from Louisiana
is a Cajun, and not everyone
who spoke French in
Louisiana was a Cajun.
>> Michael Doucet: Exactly.
Exactly. But that's what I mean,
the name, it doesn't exist.
It's all a myth, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Right, yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: So we
don't exist, you know.
I don't know why we're talking.
Why are we talking?
Anyway, yeah, you're right.
And that's because people,
you know, they have Romeros,
they have Hoffpauirs [phonetic],
that only speak French.
That was something amazing about it.
But that was a predominant language.
And that was the strength we had,
which is the strength in language,
which is the strength in community,
which evolves into music, okay.
And when that stuff
gets breaking out,
or like David was saying, put down.
I mean, we thought we were
second class citizens.
When Nick Spitzer told me in 1973
that I could get a grant, I said oh,
they give grants to Cajuns?
That's how naïve we were.
Because it was like, you know,
nobody, they'd just make fun of us.
I mean we, they made fun of us.
We were from a little
town called Scott.
We went to school in Lafayette,
and people would make fun of us
and laugh, yeah, you know,
much less go out in the world.
And then we realized oh, people
in France love this stuff
and Canada, etcetera.
So it has a different meaning.
>> Stephen Winick: So you mentioned
another band that you were in,
Coteau, talk a little
bit about that.
>> Michael Doucet: Coteau, Coteau.
You want to see a picture?
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
>> Michael Doucet: Sure.
This was the, they called
it the Cajun Grateful Dead.
What happened, it was Gary Newman,
whose father was Jimmy C. Newman,
and Jimmy C. Newman
was from Ville Platte,
and he played on the Hayride.
>> David Doucet: He
was in a hayride, yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: As did Elvis.
He was there when, Elvis ruined it.
Nobody would come after
Elvis was there.
But he found his way to Nashville,
and he did really, really well.
I mean, he wrote this
song called Cry, Cry, Cry.
And it became, you know, his song.
And anyway, so he decided,
he was on the Grand Ole Opry.
What was the question?
>> Stephen Winick: Coteau.
>> Michael Doucet: Oh Coteau, okay.
So his son, Gary, okay this
was I was, Gary came down.
This is hysterical.
>> Stephen Winick: Very nice.
>> Michael Doucet: That's us.
And then Andy Wallace just gave
me this other picture that,
this is at Wolf Trap, 1976.
>> Stephen Winick: Very nice.
>> Michael Doucet: You see that
skinny guy with the red shirt.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Michael Doucet:
We're dressed up, yeah.
And anyway.
So Coteau is, Gary, he
got some people around.
He's got Bessel de Young [phonetic],
who was, you know, a friend.
My mother used to play
cards with his mother.
And my mother used to say,
don't hang around him.
Of course, I did.
Because Bessel's father
played, recorded in 1936
with a string band,
Cajun string band.
But Bessel was a musician,
a great musician.
And so we played twin fiddles.
And it was twin guitars, drums.
And we brought the
young people together.
It was like this thing happening.
This was like from about '74 to '77.
And we really united
a lot of people,
because the old Cajuns would
come, what are you all doing?
I mean we played a
song like Mardi Gras,
which was one of the oldest songs.
And people had never heard that.
Of course, our rendition
was a little long.
But you know, it was
like, it was fun.
It was a happening time.
And it was kind of like, I
mean we're very creative,
but it was kind of like Spinal Tap.
You know, like the drummers
would like evaporate.
We lost, three of our
guitar players died.
So that's why David didn't want
to go in the group, you know.
But was just, you know.
I mean it's a hard, it's same.
So that brought a lot of awareness.
And so it also brought
a rock influence into it
but at the same time,
a folk mentality.
And that's where, when we
play, what Andy just said,
we played the National Folk Festival
it was both Coteau and BeauSoleil
because my whole idea was to do
this acoustically, like I heard it.
You know, we didn't need rock.
We didn't need a drum.
We just needed, you know, a guitar,
fiddle, accordion and percussion.
So this is the original
BeauSoleil group.
And that was enough.
That's sort of what Coteau did.
But a lot of people
still remember that.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah and
so, and then after that,
some of those influences did get
absorbed into the BeauSoleil.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah.
That was in the '80s, because
that's what they wanted.
That's what Kenner with the round
the one, he wanted the Coteau sound.
I said well, we're not
getting Coteau again, you know.
I mean it happened when it happened.
And then we tried to do it again.
In fact, we got together to do
another Coteau album, only one.
But it was like, because, anyway.
And then the guitar player
dies, and it was like, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: But I mean,
it's worked for BeauSoleil though,
to have those influences.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah, of course.
>> Stephen Winick: It sort
of made you the Cajun
band that anybody knows.
>> Michael Doucet: Well, I
don't know what that did.
But we just, we played.
I mean, you know, our thing was
to play this music in the schools.
And we had a, Dewey and I had
a grant together to do this.
And we did a lot of the
schools, taught all the way
to the university level,
you know, to educate people
about this before it's totally gone.
And I'm not talking about my
generation, people way beyond me.
And that was our, what
we really wanted to do.
But then people, like the
first year of BeauSoleil,
we played Natural Folk Festival.
We played Jimmy Carter's
inauguration in '77.
We had all these gigs,
and you know, anyway.
And so it got to the point in the
mid-80s that it was hard to hold
down a regular job and go out on the
weekends and play these festivals.
So in '85 we decided, let's
try this, let's try it.
And everybody going to jump in, give
it six months, see what happens.
So we did that in '86, and
we've been doing it ever since.
I mean it has its ebbs and flows,
but it's, we were very lucky to be
at a certain time and to know
these people and be able to play
with these people and learn
their music firsthand.
Nowadays, I mean, kids, you go on
YouTube and hear whatever you want.
But in those times,
you had to be a person.
And when you knock on a door
and somebody you don't know,
you know it's a whole
different thing to do that.
Because you don't want
to take their music,
you just want to learn their music.
So you befriend these people,
and you're friends for life.
You can't do that YouTube.
They don't [inaudible] back.
>> Stephen Winick: So we
haven't talked to Bill much.
So, you know, a lot of
what we're saying applies
to percussion as well.
There's been a lot of
changes over the years,
and I think that integration
of new sounds,
and I suppose it must
have changed what you do.
So talk a little about
that if you would.
>> Billy Ware: Well sure.
I mean I was in the, on that
original Swallow Record recording.
And I had been doing, I hadn't
been playing Cajun music.
I had been doing, with a group
of people, small group of people,
and we improvised music for
choreographers at the university.
And we would continue going through
this process and codify it so it's
in its final form for
the performances.
And I was doing, I was playing
in different size jazz groups
from a quartet to a quintet to
a septet, doing real book stuff.
And that's what I was
doing when Mike,
I get word from a mutual
friend of ours, Michael and I,
Frances [inaudible] the artist.
I'm an old friend of his.
The word was, Michael was
going to do this record,
and he wanted to know if
I wanted to participate.
So I did. So, you know, I
brought some of this to that old,
to the party, so to speak.
And I was trying to figure out
what to do basically, you know.
And because there was a certain
lightness to a lot of the way
that these songs were played.
I mean I had heard some English
folk music and things like that.
So that was part of my thinking
for those songs, you know.
And I would just apply things where
I thought percussion made sense.
You know, if we need this for
drive or color or whatever,
I would use it there, you know.
But I didn't just gratuitously
add something.
And I still don't do that.
But as far as being,
adding percussion
to Cajun music, nobody does that.
I'm the only guy, I'm standing
alone out in my field, you know.
Nobody's come after me, so I
don't know what to make of that.
But.
>> Michael Doucet: It didn't make
any sense to me that you had Billy
who was so talented,
and played triangle,
we had to get triangle from.
>> Billy Ware: I didn't even
have one for that recording.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah.
But the thing is, all our
music, we would play, you know,
exotical music, some
exotic, some creole song.
Why didn't they use drums?
That's like the basic thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: And Billy
had, you know, in his hand,
and all this kind of stuff.
And I said, that's good.
That gels the music.
That brings it all together.
It is very unique.
>> Billy Ware: Yeah,
and you can change off.
If you have a very kit, you
can change off during a song.
And it's like, and frankly, I
took that approach from looking
at early weather report stuff.
You know, from the beginning
of the 70s, you know.
And that's, I wasn't quite as
interactive and spontaneous
in my approach to applying that.
But still, just the idea that
you could use different things
in different places to articulate
and whatever, expand upon.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, it just
changes the texture during a song.
>> Billy Ware: Yeah, yeah, but
that's where I was coming from.
Frankly, that's where
I still come from.
>> Michael Doucet: With that
weather report it's going to rain.
>> Billy Ware: Not today.
It looks like, feels like 82,
mostly cloudy at night, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: So did you
even play triangle at first,
or did you have to learn that?
>> Billy Ware: No, I didn't
even own one, you know.
As matter of fact, when we
went to Floyd's Swallow Studio,
there was one lying around.
They said here, you can use this.
That was great.
It's a relief.
I've got something to play here.
And I put, you know, I don't know
if you've heard their record,
but I put all kinds of stuff on it.
It's like, well I just brought a
bunch of things, and we had to pile
in a van as I remember,
David, Michael and I.
>> Michael Doucet:
That's pretty much it.
>> Billy Ware: It was
wild, you know.
At the end of the day, we
would drive up there and work
into the night, and then we'd finish
and then drive back
afterwards, you know.
I don't even know how
long that took.
>> Michael Doucet: It
took us a long time.
>> Billy Ware: Yeah, it seemed like.
It seemed like weeks to me.
You know, so.
>> Michael Doucet: With Billy,
you got to see us trying,
Don Montece [phonetic] is an
accordion player and a bus driver,
and he's a welder, so
he made these beautiful,
beautiful triangles from rakes.
And you'd have to go to him.
And Billy's got one that's extended.
Don said, I messed up on that one.
Billy says, I love that one.
And he played it, what
was it a tractor like,
some kind of wrench or something.
>> Billy Ware: Well the triangle
is, actually Don Montece had made
that for a certain individual,
a custom [inaudible]
as they say, you know.
And I saw that.
And as Michael said,
I want that one.
He said, well, you know, that
guy, he just recently died,
so he's not going to be using it.
So I bought that one from him.
And the striker, when I was in
college, I was going walking
into a building in a field, and my
foot hit something, and I looked,
and it was a gear shift from
apparently like, you know,
like a tractor or something.
And you see this threading on
the end where the ball went,
with still like the
catalog number on the part.
But, you know, the thing is,
it's got a great balance.
>> Yeah, it sounds good.
>> Billy Ware: Because it
tapers towards the end.
And you can do that, and
it balances beautifully.
And because it's tapered, and
because it's not completely round
or flat, you can get a lot of
different tonalities out of it.
So you get like a capable Cajun
triangle like that or a [inaudible],
you can use this thing and
apply it in different ways,
and turning it this way, and you
can get subtle shifts in tonality,
which can mirror the
melody of the song.
So.
>> Stephen Winick: Excellent.
Well, we got more about
the different tonalities
of the triangle than the fiddle.
>> Michael Doucet: The
fiddle just sounds the same.
>> Right.
>> Stephen Winick: So I also
wanted to talk to Mitch about some
of the other groups that you've
been in, like Taso [phonetic]
and some of those groups.
What was the philosophy there
with other bands you've been in?
>> Mitchell Reed: Oh
yeah, with Taso,
in fact Mike produced our
record, it was to just try
to sound like the old 78 records.
And we had, we found this guy
in the swam, Philip Alamo,
he was spraying water lilies
for Wildlife and Fisheries.
But he sounded just
like these old guys.
And his accordion even, he played
one of Errol Verret's accordions.
But Mike has like the first
accordion Marc Savoy ever made.
And it's this wild accordion.
So Mike let us borrow it, and we
did a record, and Mike produced it.
And it was just really to sound
like those old 78s, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: I think
I've got that record.
>> Mitchell Reed: Oh, okay, yeah.
Oh good, good.
>> Stephen Winick: Excellent.
So good job from all of you.
>> Mitchell Reed: Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick: So great.
And the other person that's now
come up a whole bunch of times
and has also been a
musical partner of yours
for a long time, is Marc Savoy.
And so talk a little
about the Savoy influence
on Cajun music but also on you guys.
>> Michael Doucet:
You mean the dynasty?
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
the dynasty, the band.
>> Michael Doucet: Well,
the thing about Marc,
Marc is a super intelligent person,
which is unusual around
where we live.
And he's very special.
Like I said, he was born at
a certain time here he was,
one foot in one time era, the
other foot in the modern time.
And he decided, I think he's
celebrating his 50, his 50th year
or something like that,
of opening his door.
And he did that because, after he
heard that people went in Newport,
he said oh, it's going
to be popular.
So there was only one or very few
accordion makers at that time.
So he started making, because
he graduated in engineering.
And he starting making accordions
because we didn't have that,
I mean they would fall
apart, you know.
They had these old Hohners or
monarch of Sterlings for sure,
made pre-World War II Germany.
And so he started doing that.
So he was like, he was the
focal point where you find it.
And if you want to have a
[inaudible] you bring it to him.
Because it'd bring it to life.
[Inaudible].
Marc was just, and it
is, is a treasure trove
of what was going on at that time.
It just so happens it was at
that 1976 National Folk Festival
where Marc just showed up.
He actually played with us.
But he would pull me to
the side, come on Mike,
let's just jam, you know.
So we'd go to some, wherever, and
lo and behold this young woman
by the name of Ann Allen Savoy
from Richmond, Virginia, showed up,
and like was totally
enamored with the music.
And she went, and she
and Marc got together.
And that's Mrs. Savoy.
And of course, they
had kids all along.
And their kids have done, I mean
from Sarah, who's in France.
She's a chef and plays accordion.
To Joel, he was kind
of, music label.
And Wilson who plays boogie
woogie and all this stuff.
And you know, it's like
it's a very solid family.
But I mean, they're crazy
like everybody else.
And they just, it's just fun.
And the thing with this,
Marc is just very aware
about what is right, what is wrong.
I mean we've had long discussions
about, you know, in the early days,
I'm talking about in the early
70s about really the influence
of the creoles, the black creoles.
And I was always been a proponent
of Amede Ardoin because, you know,
because I just love his music.
And people in Cajun said
oh, he played too many notes
and choppy and stuff like that.
But the quality of what he played
and the creativity is just amazing.
And a lot of us didn't have
access to these things.
Although Marc, his parents, Amede
played at Marc's parents' house.
I mean and Dennis used to live
in the house he's living in now.
So it's a funny thing that happens.
So he is one of those people
that's just, it's a cornerstone,
he's a cornerstone of our society.
And that's just the way it is.
And he didn't try to be.
He doesn't want any kind of
accolades or anything like that.
And a lot of people,
oh I can do this.
And that's another lesson that, you
know, Octa used to say, Octa Clark,
he'd say, well you can't do it
wrong if you do it right, you know.
And I think that's, you just try to
do it right for the right reasons.
And so Marc has been a
great example of that.
And people sometimes are scared.
Because if he doesn't like you.
>> Yeah.
>> Michael Doucet: I mean,
don't touch that guitar.
You going to buy it?
It's time for you to leave.
You know, he doesn't care.
I mean he goes beyond
what most, anything.
You know, it's like, he's got
a sign in his shop that says,
Stradivari made 661 instruments.
The Cajuns have 2,000 of them.
You know, it's like [inaudible].
And other philosophies.
So yeah, he's quite an individual.
And the family is great.
And still, I had dinner with him
last Saturday, so alive and well.
Say hello.
>> Stephen Winick: Alright.
So another thing I wanted
to ask about was songwriter.
Because you played a couple
of songs today that you wrote.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winick:
But they, you know,
they sound like they could be
traditional songs, and certainly,
they have traditional
expressions in them.
Just the way that you
wrote them is really
in keeping with the tradition.
What's your philosophy on
that, on the songwriting?
>> Michael Doucet: Well, I haven't
written that many songs, you know,
a hundred or so, but anyway.
You know, it's nice
to do an expression.
I love traditional music.
When David and I got
together, that was it.
I mean we're just going to learn as
much as we can, different styles.
But there's a certain point, and
I use the metaphor as a wheel.
Sometimes there's a cog
missing, and you get,
you're not saying exactly
what you want to say.
So creating a song or writing
a song gives you that element.
And so you perpetuate that.
And a lot of the songs
that I like to write,
or did at some points,
was about musicians.
Like Bebe Carriere or
Freeman Fotno [phonetic],
people that most people don't know.
But to us, they're
like, they're revered.
And so songs about that.
Other songs are more modern songs.
And sometimes they work.
Sometimes they don't.
And it's wonderful to hear
people play them, you know.
But I don't write them for other
people, I write them for us.
And because it just works
really well with, like I said,
this key and things like that.
David sings this song, and
you know, things like that.
So I enjoy writing.
I don't write as much anymore.
But I still do, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Well on the
other end of that you mentioned,
there were times when people
didn't have access to some
of the older music, and they
weren't able to get them either
because they were on old 78s
or because they were
old archival recordings.
And we have an interest
in that because, you know,
this is the Library of Congress.
>> Michael Doucet: Oh,
that's where we are?
I knew it looked familiar.
>> Stephen Winick:
The recordings for.
So talk about the influence of
archival recording on [inaudible].
>> Michael Doucet: I came
here when we got a grant,
it's called the [inaudible]
studies grant at, at that time, USL.
And it was amazing grant
is that we had music.
We had language.
There's no such thing
as a Cajun dictionary.
They had been Cajun dictionaries
in the 30s and things like that.
People who studied [inaudible]
amazing stuff that we found.
Architecture, women,
creole, [inaudible].
So I was asked to teach
the Cajun or French music.
The name of my course was French
music in Louisiana, opera to zydeco.
So that' pretty vast.
One of those things that we
knew about, and I was befriended
in the early 70s, was a woman by
the name of Irene Whitfield Holmes
who wrote one of the first books.
It was her 1939 LSU thesis on
folk songs of French Louisiana.
And you know, another one,
I thought she was dead too.
My aunt says, no, she lives
right behind over there.
So I went, and we became
really good friends.
And she's the one who gave
me my first Amede Ardoin, 78,
which you could play in those days.
And she played violin.
So we played these
terrible duets together.
But she, her book, I
learned a lot in the book.
And some of my first records
where she translated Alan
and John Lomax's recordings,
transcribed.
I'd never heard it, and from her
transcriptions we recorded there
of their songs.
And then finally in
1979, I came down here
to collect the whole
Lomax collections,
and that's when Hickerson was here.
And I just, I couldn't leave.
I had never heard anything
like this.
It was so amazing.
So thanks to the Library of
Congress, and Al, of course.
We met Alan Lomax when he
came down, blah, blah, blah.
But yeah, I mean I think it, when
Alec Jabor [phonetic] was here too,
it kind of, we kind of shy.
You know, it's like
Washington, but, you know, hmm.
But once you get here, you realize
it's all run by human beings
who have the same passion
that we do.
So it kind of knocked
down those walls.
So yeah, very much appreciate being
here and being able to perform.
>> Stephen Winick.
Well we love to have you here, and.
>> Michael Doucet: Well
we're free next week.
>> Stephen Winick: Alright.
So yeah, so you know, it's now
time when I'm going to ask you guys
if there's anything else
you feel that should be said
about your tradition
about Cajun music.
>> Billy Ware: I don't
think it's dying.
>> Michael Doucet:
It's alive and well.
It's different.
It changes.
It's not the same thing.
Like David was saying, you know,
it's never going to be the same.
People have to accept that.
Cajun music kind of changes, that's
why it perpetuates itself like that.
You find more people
singing it in English.
And that's going to happen.
Because people can understand it.
You know, You're not
going to sing a song just
because people can't understand it.
That's not the point.
The point of it was
to sing in French
because that's who
your audience was.
And you know, it's hard to
deal with this to see a change.
We saw the changes in the 70s,
you know, when, well first of all,
when Will and Rodney Balfa
died February 9, 1979.
That's like the day the music died
because it was never really
the same, even for Dewey.
And then Nathan died
the year after that.
And Dewey's wife died.
And so anyway, it's
like, you, you know,
you play it because you love it,
and you live life to the fullest.
And that's what it is.
And that's still the same.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> David Doucet: People
only hear stories now.
That's what I, you know, I play
with a couple of little bands,
and I done one in a town called
Morris, Louisiana, about a month ago
with one of the Pine Leaf Boys.
And these guys are all, they
all played, but they hired them
to do this Knights
of Columbus thing.
But what they wanted to hear,
because I was there, I
knew Canray Fontenot.
They wanted to hear stories
by Canray they don't know.
They wanted to hear a
couple of stories about,
even Dewey, but also Dennis.
Nobody knows the story about
Dennis when we took him to New York
and he almost had a heart attack
when Michael stole
him out of a hospital.
And still had his electrodes on.
>> Michael Doucet: Hey Gladys.
>> David Doucet: But
things like that.
That's what people, because
they don't, there's no contact.
Those people aren't there.
We lived through that.
And so we saw this.
And it's like, you tell the
stories today and people say, no.
They don't believe any of them.
Mitchell has stories of
some of the old timers.
>> Michael Doucet: But you know,
yeah you got, the time when,
you know, James Booker
is a great piano player.
And we were just happen
to be in New Orleans.
So there were about 15 people there.
And he'd play a song,
and he'd say okay.
He had a new album.
Okay, who wants to buy an album?
Well, after 15 songs,
we all had his album.
It was his last concert.
>> He didn't play no more.
>> Michael Doucet: Fifteen people,
I've talked to about 100 people
who told me they were there.
And I said, funny I
don't remember you there.
And so you have this, even though
it's folklore and people want to.
I heard this, anyway.
So that's changed too.
So the thing is to set
it straight, you know.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well
now you have to tell a story
about Canray, because you.
>> David Doucet: There's
a lot of them.
>> Billy Ware: Well,
let me tell you.
[ Overlapped Speaking ]
>> David Doucet: Michael had
an emergency kidney stone,
and couldn't make the trip.
[ Inaudible ]
So it's like, oh, he's
hurting and all this.
>> Michael Doucet: So who
you going to get to replace?
>> David Doucet: Get
Canray to take his place.
>> Michael Doucet:
Like who else, man.
They said, what?
>> David Doucet: Yeah so, you
know, Canray, we got him a ticket.
You know, those were the old days.
You could change the
name on the ticket.
And I remember calling up.
Michael gave me his phone
number, and I talked to his wife.
She said, he's so excited, David.
He's drunk in a ditch somewhere.
I said oh my God, is he
going to show up for the gig?
We go, I don't even know
if Michael knows this.
He was my roommate.
And we'll get to that later.
We play the gig, and you know,
Canray liked to drink a little bit.
And for some reason the
promoter had a half gallon
of Early Times backstage.
And we were playing in
Charlotte, North Carolina.
And Canray, we all talked about it,
and said alright, we're going to go
and play two or three
songs, and you come out
and play the rest of the set.
We'll introduce you and all this.
No problem.
We played the three songs, Canray
come, so we play another song.
Canray. He comes out and
talks for the next 45 minutes.
Yeah, that reminds
me of another story.
Another story.
Okay, so he's a little drunk.
And we haven't eaten yet.
So we ended up, the only place
that was open in Charlotte,
North Carolina, and this is
the truth, was a Hooters.
And our agent at the time took us,
and we went to eat at a Hooters.
>> Michael Doucet: And
of course, it was awful.
>> David Doucet: But then we
all go to the hotel and it's
like Canray's my roommate, and I
didn't know he had false teeth.
And he took out his teeth
and he looked like ET.
I woke up, who are you?
Something else, man.
But he was a character.
These are stories, there's a lot of.
>> It's the right place
at the right time.
>> David Doucet: Or the time
we played for Dutch Morial
who was running for mayor, the
first black mayor of New Orleans.
And Canray was somehow
involved with this.
I do not know how, but we
had to play a fundraiser.
We all get on the stage.
Well Canray's tuned in between
standard pitch and somewhere.
>> Billy Ware: He's
like [inaudible].
>> David Doucet: You know, he was
our accordion player in the key
of C, and Canray is like
in C sharp or above.
Who knows.
And we play songs in
double keys the whole night.
It was very strong.
>> Michael Doucet: That's the way
it's supposed to sound, right.
But Canray was very, I mean he
was born, he lost his father.
He father was an accordion player,
just the same caliber
as Amede Ardoin.
But he chose not to record.
And he had to work and support his
mother and his sisters, etcetera.
So he had a hard life.
You know, he just kind
of had that on it.
And one of the, I mean there's
so many story like David says.
But one of the times is
when Chris called me up,
we went to get Canray
just to record him.
And we had to, and we went
to where he was working.
He was lifting feed seed, I mean
seed sacks, feed seed sacks.
Feed seed sacks.
Yeah, okay.
Anyway, you know what I mean.
And people who, the
proprietors of the place said,
why are you interested in, you know,
I'm not going to use the
term, but you can imagine.
And I said, well basically,
he's a genius.
And they just, you know.
And we went there that night, and
it was very, we had a great meal.
And we did the record.
And he took off his
shoes, and just his foot
like that against the floor.
So that was one of the high
points, just playing that, he and I.
But I mean he was, we played
in poor towns in 1980.
And you know, a lot
of white people there.
So Canray hits the
bottle again, and he says,
this is how he opens the concert.
I feel like a fly in a bowl of milk.
And so, but, you know, it's like.
That's a whole different
interview, man.
I'd rather get started like that.
And you know, everybody knew him.
Everybody's got their stories.
>> Billy Ware: Basically,
we were there active
in this transition point in
which we, what was fundamental
in the 19th century and the
20th century for that culture.
You know, and all those
old guys are going away.
You know.
>> Michael Doucet: But
he was amazing to know.
Several different.
>> David Doucet: Or the time we
were playing at Carnegie Hall.
We're all in the cab.
He gets out of the cab and
says, I've played here before.
>> I've been here.
Yeah. I remember that place.
>> David Doucet: He was a genius.
>> Michael Doucet: Oh yeah.
>> David Doucet: That's just him.
>> Michael Doucet: Yeah.
>> David Doucet: There's
countless others.
>> Stephen Winick: Well
one thing that, you now,
this was something you said earlier
reminded me of, you were talking
about how playing, you know,
playing English songs
is becoming more common
because people don't
understand the French songs.
But that sort of made me
think about the influence
of other French-speaking places.
You know, you recorded
your first album in France.
And Canada is sort
of a big place too.
So how is that sort of global
French community affected you guys?
>> Michael Doucet: Well, we used to,
they didn't have a
category for Cajun music.
We were world music rather.
They didn't know where to put us.
It is really world music when you
think about all the influences.
You know, it's like what
happened, it wasn't just now.
It happened in the 50s.
And a certain genre
of music that's mixed
with rockabilly and
New Orleans music.
And it's called swamp pop.
This guy, Broden [phonetic]
came up with that.
And it's rock and roll.
And one of the guys, Rod Bernard
saying [inaudible] rock and roll.
He was actually on
American Bandstand.
So it's always, you know, we
wanted to make the transition,
but they wanted to do it
with electric guitars
and things like that.
So it wasn't done with accordions.
That came later.
And Jimmy C. Newman,
you know he sings
in English too, etcetera, like that.
So you know, all that,
Kershaw, [inaudible] too.
I mean it's slowly it's there.
And I think for it to survive, it
has to regenerate to something else.
As long as it's real, you know.
>> Stephen Winick: Well you
guys definitely play real music.
I think we can all say that.
>> Michael Doucet:
That's all we know.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yeah, well alright.
I want to thank you very
much for this interview.
It's been a great time
sharing stories about
>> Michael Doucet: My pleasure.
>> Stephen Winick: Cajun
music and French music.
>> Michael Doucet: That's
what we talked about.
That's right.
>> Stephen Winick: Alright,
thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.